[Music]
if your history class sometimes seems
boring it is because your teachers
aren't telling you about the most
interesting historical facts sometimes
they are even just lying to you but we
can't blame them this is what their
teachers told them decades ago but it is
now time to find the truth about what
happened in the past did you know that
Napoleon wasn't actually short make sure
to watch this video to know where this
myth comes from and for more funny
stories if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are finally
telling you about 10 historical facts
they don't teach you in school
Christopher Columbus
we know Columbus as the man who
discovered America and who wanted to
prove that the earth is round our
teachers told us that the Italian
Explorer wanted to find a quicker and
safer way to reach Asia by traveling
west his goal was to prove that it was
possible to travel around the globe but
instead he accidentally found America
the rest is history even though this
story is true that doesn't make him the
first man to discover the continent
Native Americans were there thousands of
years ago late in the Ice Age this only
makes the navigator a man who stole
their land and Christopher Columbus was
not the first European to discover
America either nearly 500 years before
his birth a group of Vikings found the
new world you might think that Columbus
at least proved that the earth is round
but that is also a myth over 2,000 years
ago Pythagoras was the first to mention
this idea Aristotle later proved
physical evidence by looking at the
Stars
moreover Eratosthenes even managed to
estimate the Earth's circumference using
basic geometry so Christopher Columbus
might be the reason why so many of us
now live in America but this man
certainly doesn't deserve all the credit
for these discoveries we can't believe
that our history teacher had been lying
to us all this time Caligula made his
horse a console there are some
historical facts or teachers don't want
us to know about simply because they
don't make sense at all but you'll be
surprised to see that this story is true
Roman Emperor Caligula really made his
horse a console and that's not the only
crazy thing he did this man was in love
with his horse and potatoes he gave it a
marble stall and I remainder a jeweled
collar and a house servants even fed
into taters oats mixed with gold flakes
Caligula was known for his madness when
he was not obsessed with his Horace he
had conversations with the moon but
let's go back to the horse a historian
gave a logical reason to explain why
into titus became a console Caligula
treated his horses way to humiliate
senators and other elites they were
shocked to see that a horse had more
things that they could ever wish for but
what was even more insulting was to see
that their job was so meaningless that
even an animal could do it and sometimes
we think that a horse could share great
ideas as a consult free carrots for
everyone Lincoln didn't believe that
everyone was equal Abraham Lincoln was
known as the man who declared that all
slaves should be forever free he
believed that slavery was morally wrong
and did his best to stop it but the
politician was not perfect in fact he
didn't know exactly what she be done
about slaves within the political system
abolitionists wanted slavery to be
immediately abolished and freed slaves
to become equal members of the society
but the politician wasn't sure was a
good thing so even though Lincoln had a
good idea he didn't clearly know how to
make things change but that is not the
worst mistake he made Abraham Lincoln
just didn't believe that white and black
people were equal he didn't want black
people to be slaves but he wasn't in
favor of the social and political
equality of the two races either the
politician didn't think that black men
and women should have the right to vote
serve on juries hold office or
intermarry with whites he only believed
that their condition should be improved
and that they deserve to be paid for
their work his views later evolved over
the course of his presidency but we
shouldn't forget about what he said so
even if he had some new ideas at that
time we wouldn't think he was a good
person nowadays witches weren't burned
at the stake you have all heard about
the Salem witch trials
1692 people started suffering from
seizures and contortions a physician
diagnosed the children as being victims
of black magic they needed someone to
blame so they decided that many women
were responsible for this
using witchcraft 20 people were executed
because they were believed to be witches
this story is true but not the way their
life ended these women weren't burned at
the stake in accordance with the English
law they were hanged there was also a
man amongst them who was executed with
heavy stones but they are not the only
victims of the Salem trial many women
passed away behind bars while awaiting
their trial but why do most people think
that witches were burned at the stake it
was inspired by European witch trials at
that time execution by fire was a common
practice it is believed that between the
15th and the 18th centuries 50,000
people were executed as witches in
Europe this tragedy happened because of
a feeling that still exists nowadays we
fear what we don't know and we hate what
we fear this is why men call these women
witches and wanted to eliminate them and
do you know what is the best defense
against this way of thinking it is
education this is why our history
classes are so important Jesus wasn't
born in December we have been
celebrating Christmas on the wrong day
during all these years and that's not
the worst mistake we made Jesus wasn't
born in year 1 either this means that
the term BC or before Christ doesn't
make sense the only things that we know
about his birth were written in the New
Testament but the Gospel of Matthew in
the Gospel of Luke each told a different
story anyway there was nothing about any
specific calendar dates so historians
had to find other ways to know when the
Son of God was born
it is really implausible that Mary and
Joseph travelled from Nazareth to
Bethlehem in the middle of the winter
moreover the light they saw in the sky
might be explained by different rare
astronomical events they happened in 5
BC June 2nd BC and October 7 BC nothing
could confirm which date was the right
one but most scholars agree that the
Christ was probably not born on December
25th year
but why have we been celebrating
Christmas during the winter during all
these years the church thought it was a
good opportunity to add Christmas to all
the other winter celebrations of other
pagan religions Christmas had nothing to
do with the Christ after all a secret
chamber was built in Mount Rushmore
if you watched the movie national
treasure Book of Secrets you have
probably heard about the chamber that
was built in Mount Rushmore even though
it is not as impressive as what you saw
in the movie this story was not far from
reality the chamber was originally
intended to hold some of America's most
treasured documents hidden behind the
hairline of Abraham Lincoln was an
18-foot tall doorway to this room but
unfortunately this secret chamber was
left unfinished and there was no reason
to keep it secret
there was no legendary city of gold or
national treasure to be found either if
you ever go through that doorway you
will find nothing more than an empty
room approximately 75 feet in length
with a 35 foot tall ceiling but that is
not the only fascinating thing you need
to know about Mount Rushmore did you
know that Thomas Jefferson was a do-over
Jefferson was supposed to be on
Washington's right but after 18 months
of carving the sculptor changed his mind
and dynamited Jefferson off the mountain
he was then sculpted again on
Washington's lap we'll never see the
Mount Rushmore the same way again now
that you know about this but we have to
admit that we still hope there is a
treasure hidden somewhere in the Black
Hills Mary Antoinette never said let
them eat cake
you might have heard this story during
your history class it was believed that
during the French Revolution the Queen
was told that her starving peasants
subjects had no bread to eat according
to the legend Mary Antoinette answered
let them eat cake because of that many
people thought that she knew nothing
about the condition of ordinary people
and it was an insult to them but the
truth is she probably never said that
there is absolutely no historical
evidence that it happened
Jean Jacques Rousseau was the first
person to report that a great princess
used this specific phrase but he never
said that this princess was Mary
Antoinette actually she was still a
child at the time but since Russo's
writing inspired the revolution this
quote was falsely credited to Mary
Antoinette they used it as a way to
rouse opposition to the
monarchy and then the rumor was repeated
so many times that people thought it was
a fact to prove that this is nothing but
a myth scholars have found similar tales
in other parts of the world it was not
the first time a noblewoman was accused
of saying this kind of thing to the
hungry poor did you believe in that
story we have to admit that we never
thought our teachers could be lying to
us van Gogh didn't cut his ear even if
this legend sounded crazy we all
believed it the painter had a mental
illness so he began having
hallucinations this is when he took a
razor and cut his own ear he later
painted self-portrait with bandaged ear
to immortalize this moment but van Gogh
recalled nothing about the event and the
reason why he didn't remember it might
be that this is not what happened
actually he lost his ear in a sword
fight with his friend a French artist
named Paul Goodwin he wrapped it in a
cloth walked into a building and
presented the ear to a woman who quickly
fainted then van Gogh went home to sleep
and would have passed away if the police
didn't find him the next morning
historians believe that the painter
himself said that he was the one who cut
off his own ear because he wanted to
protect his friend the two men both kept
a pact of silence and they made sure no
one knew about this event until
historians read the letters written by
the two artists this is how they found
out that goo-gooing was the responsible
one for this what would you do if your
friend accidentally harmed you would you
have the courage to pretend to be crazy
to protect them don't be shy to tell us
what you think in the comments
Simeon the elder lived on a pillar the
reason why your teacher didn't tell you
about this story is probably that it is
meaningless but we are going to tell you
about this anyway because it is so funny
st. simians delight is also known as
Simeon the elder was the first known
pillar hermit after being expelled from
a monastic community he wanted to get
away from the hoards of disciples and
onlookers who came to visit him this is
why he decided to spend the rest of his
life on the top of a pillar his first
column was six feet high but he later
lived on a column that was 50 feet high
he was always exposed to the Sun the
wind in the rain he had to be standing
or sitting day and night
but how did he survive during all these
years he was provided with a ladder to
communicate with people and they gave
him food his pillar even became a
pilgrimage site people visited him to
receive spiritual advice to be relieved
from sickness and find enlightenment in
prayer
Simeon converted many people and even
influenced a Roman Emperor he passed
away after spending forty seven years in
prayer and contemplation on his pillar
from what we know Simeon the elder was
probably the most patient man who ever
lived on earth
Napoleon wasn't short we all believed
that Napoleon was short after all this
is what our teachers told us and we
trusted them the Napoleon complex was
named after him to describe men who have
an inferiority complex people believe
that smaller men acted quickly and
aggressively to scare off bigger
competition but was it the reason why
this leader was a master tactician the
myth was that Napoleon Bonaparte a was 5
feet to the day he passed away and this
fact is true but that doesn't mean he
was short the politician leader was
measured in French units at that time in
modern international units he would
actually be 5 feet 7 he might think that
is still short but at that time in
France the average height for a man was
about 5 feet 5 so he was taller than
them the reason why people might have
nicknamed him the little corporal was
because he was standing next to really
tall personal bodyguards or maybe there
was a reason why people decided to make
fun of him it was said that Napoleon had
a habit of spoiling women's clothing
when he didn't like the way they look he
just spilled ink or food on them to make
it unwearable now that we know about
this we don't mind that people still
think Napoleon is short he probably
deserved that unfortunate reputation and
that's it for 10 historical facts they
don't teach you in school which one
surprised you the most don't forget to
tell us in the comments down below and
make sure you like this video if you
believed in one of these myths and for
more stories like this make sure to
watch 10 amazing pictures they won't
show you in history books thanks for
watching
[Music]